>> YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A GREAT
TIME.
WELCOME AGAIN.
>> A LOT OF TESTS IN COLLEGE
UNPREPARED.
>> EXACTLY RIGHT.
THIS IS WHERE WE BEGIN -- WITH
THE CDC LIFTING THE MASK
MANDATES.
JUST IN TIME FOR YOUR VACATION
SEASON.
SO WE'RE STARTING A WEEK-LONG
SERIES WE'RE CALLING "SPRING
INTO SUMMER."
WE'RE GOING TO LOOK AT WHAT TO
EXPECT, YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU MAKE
THE SUMMER PLANS, YOU TRY TO GET
BACK TO NORMAL.
ANYBODY DOING THAT?
ALL THIS WEEK, WE HAVE
CORRESPONDENTS SPREAD ALL AROUND
THE COUNTRY AT TOP TRAVEL
DESTINATIONS.
WE'RE GOING TO START HERE IN
GOOD OLD NEW YORK CITY WITH
ERROLL BARNETT.
HE HAS A CLOSER LOOK AT TWO WAYS
MOST OF US WILL GET TO THE HOT
SPOTS -- PLANES AND CARS.
>> Reporter: THE UNOFFICIAL
START TO SUMMER IS MEMORIAL DAY
WEEKEND.
AND FOR MANY, THAT MEANS A
ROADTRIP.
AAA PREDICTS 34 MILLION PEOPLE
WILL DRIVE TO THEIR DESTINATION.
THAT IS A MAJOR JUMP FROM LAST
YEAR'S 23 MILLION, BUT IT'S
STILL LOWER THAN FROM BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC.
STILL, WHEN YOU PULL UP TO A GAS
STATION LIKE THIS ONE, YOU MIGHT
BE IN FOR A BIG SURPRISE.
THE AVERAGE PRICE OF REGULAR GAS
IS NOW WELL ABOVE $3 PER GALLON
WHICH IS A REAL PAIN POINT FOR
MANY AMERICANS' PERSONAL
FINANCES.
BUT PANDEMIC RESTRICTIONS ARE
EASING, AND FOLKS ARE EAGER TO
GET OUT.
SO WHERE'S EVERYBODY GOING?
AAA FOUND THE TOP DRIVING
DESTINATIONS HAVE EITHER SUN,
SAND, ORRE SERENITY IN COMMON.
FLORIDA AND CALIFORNIA BEACHES
ARE POPULAR AS IS THE GULF OF
MEXICO, THE CAROLINAS, AND ALL
THE BIG NATIONAL PARKS.
EVEN WHEN IT COMES TO AIR
TRAVEL, AMERICANS DON'T WANT TO
TREK TOO FAR.
ROUGHLY THREE MILLION ARE
EXPECTED TO FLY THIS HOLIDAY
WEEKEND.
WITH TOP DESTINATIONS INCLUDING
HAWAII, THE CARIBBEAN, AND
MEXICO.
SOME HAVE EVEN TAKEN TO CALLING
THIS REVENGE TRAVEL BECAUSE OF
ALL THE CANCELATIONS AND MISSED
TRIPS OVER THE PAST YEAR.
SO NO MATTER WHAT YOUR TRAVEL
PLANS MAY BE, REMEMBER -- COVID
IS STILL OUT THERE, VACCINATIONS
ARE REQUIRED BY SOME COUNTRIES,
AND EVEN FOLKS LIKE ME WHO ARE
FULLY VACCINATED STILL ARE
RECOMMENDED TO KEEP ONE OF THESE
MASKS HANDY BECAUSE AS THEY SAY,
LIVING WELL IS THE BEST REVENGE.
CONSIDER "CBS THIS MORNING," I'M
ERROLL BARNETT AT JFK AIRPORT IN
NEW YORK.
>> ALSO LIVING WELL JUST FEELS
GOOD.
>> SURE DOES.
>> IT GETS YOU IN THE MOOD --
DID YOU SAY -- HAWAII, MEXICO,
AND THE CARIBBEAN ARE THE TOP
PLACES.
>> YEAH.
>> SO FAR.